demandant leur sens du devoir l'hôpital
tient le système sanitaire tient alors
même qu'il est soumis à une pression
considérable
nous savons tous au fond ce que nous
leur devons traduisant la volonté du
président de la république nous
verserons donc une prime exemple de tout
prélèvement fiscal ou social
c'est-à-dire net de tous 2500 euros à
tous les personnels qui gère la crise du
coc vite de 19 dans les hôpitaux des
départements les plus touchés ainsi que
au personnel des services ayant acquis
ayant accueilli des patients que vides
dans les départements les moins touchés
et pour tous les autres personnels des
hôpitaux ne bénéficiant pas du taux
maximal tels que je viens de le décrire
nous verserons 500 euros le gouvernement
a aussi décidé que les heures
supplémentaires effectuées à l'hôpital
pendant la crise sanitaire serait
valorisée beaucoup plus fortement que
les heures supplémentaires habituel à
hauteur de 50% en plus le gouvernement
souhaite également qu'une prime soit
versée au personnel qui remplissent une
mission décisive au sein des ehpad et
des services à domicile du secteur
médico social
nous devons en la matière échanger avec
les collectivités locales en particulier
avec les départements qui en sont
souvent les financeurs pour déterminer
les conditions de financement de cette
prime à côté des soignants de la
fonction publique hospitalière à côté de
l'ensemble des personnels de la fonction
publique hospitalière il ya les autres
agents de la fonction publique d'état et
aussi de la fonction publique
territoriale pour la fonction publique
d'état
certains agents ont fait preuve d'un
engagement remarquable alors en tant
qu'employeur l'état souhaite marquer sa
reconnaissance envers ses personnels à
travers le versement d'une prime
défiscaliser d'un montant maximal de
1000 euros nets
modulable en fonction de la durée
d'engagement des agents pour la fonction
publique territoriale nous offrons la
possibilité aux employeurs la
possibilité de verser dans les mêmes
conditions d'exemption de prélèvement
fiscal ou social
un maximum
2000 euros par agent